hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Spooky's House of
jump-scares I was actually gonna stop
playing and I decided to keep rolling
immediately long because I'm really
really really interested in this game
and I want to see what it has in store
for me I know there's probably a lot
more spooks waiting for me down in your
drab spell finding schism form below
down there and meet them right now like
I know I don't know if this is like just
the demo I can't remember if this is the
demo of the gamers it's actually the
full game like depending on how long
this game is like oh this is new I'll
judge it for what it's worth at the end
of it but so far I gotta say I'm very
well that's a bad sound okay what is
this gonna do haven't I already been
here before
I don't think there's gonna be anything
new is there damn it okay I don't think
there's any point to this I already got
this I'm out of here yeah I don't like
turning my back to nothing
oh this is weird and white and foggy
hello who are you
these are the youtubers hey that that do
I think that is I'm not gonna say names
just in case that's not who I think it
is and then I totally embarrass my but
you all y'all know who I was thinking of
when I saw that right y'all know my
school oh okay burn I do that but I
haven't seen this layout in a while this
game and it's constant whoa what that's
okay we went we went full-on horror mode
no thanks oh god what is this broken
broken you could have just said lock
that would have believed you broke it
that was it wasn't broken oh maybe it
was a reflection on me the darkness is
slowly consuming us now I don't think I
did you look easy much longer how are we
supposed to know this would happen I
wonder if the Spooky's House of
jump-scares like an actual SCP on its
own entity I mean someone world
what is that what am I looking at right
now I don't want to know it's not really
our fault we just did what mother had
told us to do in this soda situation
okay whose mother whose mama broken
broken just like me
a former shell of my former self mother
is not pleased with us but how are we
supposed to know the girl wasn't pure
what's appear in what way what does that
mean sacrificing virgins are we oh hi
who the hell do you think you are
there's nothing in here all right bye
weird noises in the darkness love my
broken doors that one part up nope
they gave a Boop here a breezy Oh
goddamn breathing oh this again
don't kill me bro don't get me wrong
[Music]
was there something there okay okay am i
alive no foggy no thank you
are you kidding me with this ball what
is crime fair Oh Oh God what is I think
it's hiding the doors on me Hey
why'd you turn into radical Larry not
okay not okay not okay
not okay not okay oh god he's back again
I think I gotta just go quickly or else
he's gonna find me oh god oh god I can't
see you dancing oh man I gotta hurry
time for you here
oh god again with this yeah this is
gonna be a constant occurrence in my
life now God was with him
oh god I know what he's doing he's
trying to confuse me and hide the door
on me but I know these levels I know I'm
like for that like wag okay so what
normal again this is gonna stay normal
it's a question probably not until I get
to 250 I'm guessing yep it's gonna keep
doing this all the way to 250 Wow
too bad for you I'm an expert I am an
expert I said I wonder if he's still
like right he's still right by me isn't
it
I'm not gonna wait around to find out
because I don't want to end this I don't
I am this too quickly now
this is really cool I gotta admit like
the initial shock faster factor is worn
off quite a bit but I mean how it's
really cool it's totally unexpected like
that's what I was talking about catching
me off guard that's the ideal of what it
should be when it's trying to scare
somebody catch him off-guard totally
throw him for a loop and that way the
shocks their panics panic like god that
was the word I was trying to find a
while ago I just couldn't think of it
panic is like the main thing that you
need in a horror game you need people to
panic because the fight-or-flight
response has to be kicked into overdrive
to really give people the shot of
adrenaline that they seek because whoa
I've been here before
I don't want to be here again good bye
now
yeah that have rental in rustling horror
game junkies like myself that's what we
crave like I wouldn't play horror games
if I didn't love to play like some
people whoa what is this
Mall of the spook oh my god it's game
within a game oh my god I games so why
am i what
[Music]
okay I don't know if there was I'm
ending it who could've Boogedy Boogedy
Boogedy I can't oh I'm not
pac-man I sure did thanks
sorry game password is pumpkin pumpkin
like guys that your nickname for me
what's in this present
[Music]
okay you don't look happy
were you happy before all right then
moving right along I'm gonna try to get
to level 300 before I end this
particular episode gathers so much oh my
god this game is just dripping with
content probably not the right word to
use for that nope dang yeah yeah I did
it I'm getting good at that one now
notice for them and there's only a few
set patterns that have been going for it
but I don't know if that's just my luck
it's usually left left or right right
forward forward God again with you
radical larry jelly or octopus i don't
know why you are exactly I don't think I
want to know what you are exactly Oh
actually is it's so weird because I feel
like those other levels like the
classroom and the underground level
we're like Oh Mars is two different
horror games of the past maybe now I
don't know what the thing referring to
mother was but I feel like this game
collects you hello collects other scary
things and puts them all in one place in
that way it's kind of like SCP I did
hear a noise again god damn it
FLAC alright shut up over there not you
guys something happened right behind the
DVD over there weird noises happening
late at night don't much care for it
ding ding
damnit see it's always the same set
pattern bang okay
shut up someone's trying to get in no
one's here no one should be here no one
should be here shut up
just trying to get to level 300 before I
lose my mind
I mean I'm able to get through this game
relatively quickly I will admit that I
don't think it was gonna let me do
anything is it why is it cat daus yeah I
thought so
I've already been to they said I don't
need to read anymore exit program thank
you
I mean wait tonight whoa alright was I
introduced to a new element in level 250
to 300 yet I don't think I was was I
another thing anything new happened and
I feel like something might hey damn it
yeah I got it okay this is always a pain
in the butt just a little bit of a time
sync to keep me staying in one place
long enough for something to creep up
behind me am i right game I'm right
aren't I got like my body postures
probably alway thrown off because I'm
like kind of apprehensive kind of like
me
shut up don't do anything yeah there we
go
darling noises what I'm in that one I
very much worry about it I very much
stress that something's gonna come out
of me at that particular juncture hi
okay you know what I haven't run into
the long hallway that I died to in the
first god this Frank Frank
damn it damn it
there we go God ah those are gonna get a
pain I got more on this particular okay
that's new those are new sounds good I
mean what are you doing no no nothing
oh no oh no oh no no no no no no no god
damn it I can't run Oh Bobby
oh no no no no no no okay all right I
was about to say if you were gonna kill
me in corner me I was gonna be very
upset but right now I got a spider on my
butt yeah I don't know why I got a
spider on my butt spiders that really
the most terrifying thing ever I don't
have a rocket phobia so I'm fine
I really don't know how many levels are
in this game in total those noises are
getting louder hello thank you hanging
in there
I'm gonna keep going because I don't
know if this game is like gonna suddenly
end after a certain point but I want to
get through another 50 levels just to be
sure because for all I know there could
be like a thousand levels the door is
getting a little more decrepit it's time
I go down a level oh all right then
[Music]
do ya for me locked that's new
what do you mean locked I've never seen
that happen before on these layouts whoa
all right then okay seems a little quiet
for being this deep into the house if I
am even in the house anymore if it could
be considered that maybe I just been
looping around the same room over and
over again
[Music]
what is this Legend of Zelda this feels
a lot like Legend of Zelda
[Music]
okay what no what the hell it totally is
it's some creepy version of The Legend
of Zelda creepypasta Zelda one day a
strange Burton came to town he sold
handmade puppets and trinkets and all
the children loved his store and his
gifts but the town couldn't support his
store because the other shops were
failing the other shopkeepers became
jealous so one night some of the
townspeople took all his puppets threw
them in a river cool story bro but just
afterwards it came running to the river
crying and wailing that his children
were being drowned he dove into the
river trying to save his possessions the
townspeople bitter and still angry
watched him frantically thrash and dive
into the river until he never came back
to the surface of the water what a bunch
of two [ __ ] one Oh same thing what a
bunch of a-holes well a bunch of stupid
towns folk wow it's not a one oh where
are those keys in the other room and I
think they might actually have keys on
the table they're like right tools tools
key area I thought so
it didn't exactly look like a key being
a 2d representation of a texture on a
table there but I I figured it out with
my brilliant mind
whoa thank you I was bloody years later
the children of the town began to go
missing and as more and more children
disappeared people began to find more
and more puppets and the forest stood
around the river these puppets seemed
almost to look like the children missing
sometimes oh yeah no coincidence there
although now what they wanted the
shopkeepers were satisfied oh okay I got
I read the head in the wrong order
[Music]
well hey how's it going there how's it
going there oh hi
how are you you got you got you got a
damn oh you look friendly
oh you look fun what is that in your
hand
[Music]
hi woody buddy buddy buddy all right
oh okay oh you're an SCP thing now are
you
[Music]
hey where's that damn door where's the
damn door for the hello where's the
Darius Oh nope nope nope you gonna give
me where's Sam
where am i okay is it something baloney
this had nothing to do with the puppet
that said nothing to do with the puppets
said now the goddamn thing to do with
the puppets screw you screw your puppets
hello okay bye go through all these
backwards now so those won't work on me
not anymore
I've grown up
[Music]
he's gonna appear when I'm walking
behind on it god this
is he still is he still gonna whoa okay
I think that answers my question
the answers yes is still there
[Music]
got this weird this is weird this is
really weird
hi okay not not the time for it bros
skele bros not the time i got an issue
here
[ __ ] like this it makes me paranoid and
unable to sleep at night oh god where is
it oh not that's crap crap I'm a lucky
son of a [ __ ] I don't know who's coming
up behind me oh this sucks this sucks
majorly god this sucks
I do everything backwards hi okay I
thought something else was behind me oh
crap
dang go the wrong way see there God I
got nothing else to say at the moment
I'm concentrating very hard not to die
so everyone just bear with me till I get
to room 350 then we can end this episode
and I can move on with my life I mean I
will admit like it's kind of a carbon
copy of scp-173 or 1 7 3 is that even
his name hey you know what I mean you
know which one the big concrete thingy
but I mean still
so is that sever your take on things
[Music]
dammit god dammit I really don't know if
I still have the patience for it
yeah get out of my way pumpkin bro god
damn it yes sons of [ __ ] running me
out of sprint running me out of life
almost yeah just a few more few more you
more I mean I don't know it's gonna suck
if this guy is still there after I get
through the save point I don't know if
he will I don't know I don't even know
if he's still here now I think he might
have left but I'm not gonna risk that
wait hell is there any way I could like
check to see if he's still there okay I
think he actually might have gone yeah
yeah
where's my same point where's my same
point with my same point oh no not this
guy again
why is he here what are you doing
there's no time for this am I getting to
the end of the game is he gonna like
loop through back through the other
things that I've done before I'm getting
to the end of the game
this feels very end game ish whoa I'm
gonna get through the last fifty-fifty
things if this really is in line go away
go to time that gut thing by me
I gotta go go goo goo I gotta go goo goo
balls that no no no God what is that
something keeps shaking me and stopping
me in my tracks they're gonna mix it in
the guy's gonna come back and I'm gonna
have to go through this backwards and
with all this [ __ ] hello just get
away don't have time for that
don't have time for any of that I'm
gonna beat this damn game just you wait
just you wait maybe eventually God these
levels just take forever to get through
ah
there's so many of them why did it have
to be so Makani oh I see come on come on
come on Kenneth you ten more you tell me
more
keep going stall for time shut up no
time gotta go gotta go no time
wait a minute they're quiet again
some behind me maybe got quiet
I don't like quiet oh oh oh okay alright
we're fine false alarm
everything's still okay feels feels
wrong feels wrong something feels wrong
something feels very wrong I like it
[Music]
thanks shot up
I like this I don't like this I don't
like this I don't like it I'm gonna like
it I don't like it oh my gosh I love it
oh yeah where's that where's that what
was that was that that was like a
Windows sound the hell is that
why was that a thing
[Music]
okay almost a 400 you better give me a
goddamn checkpoint at 400
you better believe that leader goddamnit
the brain in the jar who's that
did you hear that [ __ ] with me you
guys hear that you just heard that right
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
what am I not done yet is this a down
button always that blood around it I'm
an auntie I don't want to play anymore
I'm done I'm done it if I'm close to the
end let me know maybe there's only 500
levels will you let me know so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
[Music]